this is john collins
the world record holder for paper
aircraft distance
you might remember john from the micro
dock we made about him a while back
and today he's going to teach us how to
fold some world-class paper airplanes
so i named the world record plane after
my wife the name of the design is
suzanne
this is how you fold suzanne
you start with the short side of the
paper up you take the top of the page
and put it against the left side making
a big diagonal
you unfold that
and then you take the top of the page
and put it against the right side making
the other diagonal
[Music]
so now when you unfold that you've got
an x in the page now with the first step
after that is to take the right hand
edge from the crease corner down to the
other crease and put that against the
diagonal fold
you do the same thing for the left side
you can either unfold that
edge or leave it folded and move the
other edge over
then you make a fold straight down the
top of the plane gets folded down right
straight across the center of that x
you have to line up the top of the
diagonals with the bottom of the
diagonals
one long crease from the top layer to
the bottom layer because in the next
move you're going to use those diagonal
creases you're going to fold those just
following the existing creases
now if you're not going to use tape
you're allowed to use tape on the world
record plane if you're just going to
lock it together and have a little fun
with this design you take the tab that's
pointed down and fold it up over the two
corners you just moved to the center
then you fold the plane in half
[Music]
and then you make the wing fold
[Music]
fast paper airplane
yep you throw it like a football the
faster it spins the straighter it flies
and you can also demonstrate
centrifugal force and processional
forces with this aircraft
and another unique part of this aircraft
is that the center of gravity is not
actually on the aircraft every rotate
every object rotates around its center
of gravity the center of gravity on this
one is right there in thin air
roll over about a third
it's okay if it's a little bit more than
the third
fold the third in half
fold that in half again we're going to
start turning it
into a circle
unfold
last time we folded it in half
put one end inside the other and then
remake this crease
[Music]
and then just lock the back of it
together
with just a little tuck right there
[Music]
this was one of those lucky planes that
it came unchanged right out of my head
and when you see the folding technique
you're going to go what's going on in
that guy's head
we're going to start with the short side
up
and we're going to fold in half
and now we're going to find the halfway
point the midpoint on this long creased
edge here and making just a little pinch
now we're going to find the one quarter
point which is the midway point between
our half point
we're going to use our quarter point
we're going to make a crease that goes
from the quarter point up to this corner
right here now we're going to squash
this flap right here
and open it up
and press it flat
flip it over and fold that flap the
other direction now what we're going to
do is start to put these points into
these pockets take this point down and
line it up with the bottom of the pocket
i'm going to flip it over
and i'm going to make another crease
what we're going to do now is start to
narrow this even more so in order to
narrow it enough to go in there
i'm actually going to roll this up and
over
[Music]
i'm just going to narrow it so that it
fits
just inside this triangle
now you can press it all flat
a lot going on let's do the other side
we've been up here like this
we want to go down just before we get to
this point here
so that we're just inside there now
we're gonna lift and narrow
just to the inside
insert it into the pocket
and press it flat
so we were down like this and now we're
going up like that
[Music]
now we're going to do
a squash fold on the front part of the
plane
now we're gonna flip it over
and i'm gonna fold the nose back
just between these two shoulder points
right here
now we're going to fold it in half
now we just need to make wings and
winglets and we're just about there
[Music]
and now we're just going to make some
winglets
i start parallel with the main wing fold
i'll get these guys parallel with that
crease
we'll lift the winglets so that they're
vertical let me get the uh
the correct wing trim here
this is a superb stunt plane circles
left circles right does a loop uh it'll
even do two loops outside if you if you
trim it uh
the really shallow up elevator you can
get it to actually do two loops in one
flight one will be a giant loop and the
other one might be a little kick loop at
the bottom as it comes around to recover
from the first big loop you'll see what
i mean take it outside and have some fun
this is the boomerang one
[Music]
if you enjoyed this video and want to
learn more click the link to check out
john's great big story